[Music]
this story is good because i think it's
a good chance to get
a great opinion from the everyman
about netflix
so yeah let's talk some [ __ ] y'all
didn't dip like a [ __ ]
yeah so netflix did dip
uh it dipped pretty massively the stocks
dropped 37 percent
50 billion in value wow and in a quarter
where they were thinking that they were
going to increase by um they predicted
2.5 million new subs for i think that
year they actually started the quarter
off losing 200k yeah
wow no
no
yeah the thing is it's like there's so
many you know obviously they have a lot
of investors that they have to kind of
like quell
um and a lot of the reasons for why this
happened
don't really sound too good like they're
saying like oh it's because
there's uh not a lot of broadband
support in a lot of areas or that like
they're it's too slow the growth of
broadband
availability but
you kind of think is that the reason
i thought we got over that problem yeah
i thought it was if i never heard
broadway i felt like it was just the
relapse of the pandemic yeah that's
another reason like everyone everyone
like had like uh like what was crazy is
the minute the pandemic hit right
everyone was adopting that lifestyle so
everyone was subscriptions like crazy
and what was nuts was uh even for on the
barbell brigade site our joggers were
selling out like crazy because everyone
was gonna be at home everyone's just
chilling like the most random items that
we never thought would sell out were
selling out and then i think now that
people are coming out and feel more safe
it's just the swing back oh yeah yeah
they're not going to stay home and maybe
watch netflix especially because their
prices went up yeah and then there's no
new content and [ __ ] are they returning
all the joggers
[Laughter]
all the people that built businesses on
just like masks what are they going to
do bro they're both talking about cages
like that bro
yeah what are you going to do now kenz
but yeah the uh there's tons of reasons
they gave that is one of them they think
the stay at home orders are a big part
of it also
uh this one they said is that a lot of
people are sharing passwords now that's
what i was doing i got like 10 people on
mine bro you didn't say that they've
been doing that though right exactly
they've been that's not new why are they
saying
like they're aware of that yeah
but i mean i think as a response from a
lot of uh like tech people or like uh
channels that are reviewing this they're
saying that it's
it's due to the content not being as
good yeah i kind of agree really but
ozarks is on there i watched it in 2021
but if you watch all the stuff it's all
done yeah you know what i've been on you
know like when you have your plate of
food ready to eat and you're just like
looking for something yeah my food be
getting cold lately you never will find
anyone i'm just like scrolling it's
because i've watched everything too yeah
but also they they give you too much
content at once they need to do like the
slow drift like hbo does a good job at
once a week in one episode they dropped
the whole season of ozark people
watching one day and never which is
which is kind of cool but also it's like
you don't appreciate the show after a
while people were talking about euphoria
forever yeah yeah that's why i wait
until it's all dropped and then i go and
watch it when i'm not really cool
because everyone's talking about it then
i watch it afterwards
like what do you guys watch like what do
you guys go on netflix for to watch
i'm watching versailles right now
there's this there's this new show it's
obama talking about i love that show
that's what we've been watching yeah oh
yeah
i was watching that actually an animal
too animal's really good obama talked
about what he's like it's just nature
bro it's so cool it's honestly he's such
a good narrator because his voice man
yeah yeah i've been watching like random
documentaries yeah
yeah yeah like murder ones you watch
murder docs murder ones and also there's
like there was this one called bad vegan
oh i heard about that oh man that one
was nuts it's pretty [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's right
and like the tinder swindler and stuff
like oh yeah i keep forgetting about
that one like those ones i'm like okay
keep doing that because i'll watch for
that but all the netflix original stuff
i haven't touched was squid games on
netflix yeah it was yeah so that's
probably their last big that was their
hitter that one and then they just had
that movie with uh ryan reynolds called
the atom project oh yeah you know what
that was pretty good that was actually
really good too wait wasn't was netflix
don't look up don't look up yeah but i i
like i agree with that but also i
wouldn't want them to change it how they
like drop everything at once because i
like that because then i'll sit there
and binge it but that's how i watch
shows yeah but also it would make more
sense right because like hbo i was
watching the show with john cena and
like every thursday they released an
episode so you have to sit there and
wait and wait and wait so it makes sense
are we pretty universal in the fact that
we all kind of don't watch netflix as
much now yeah i have a kid so i just
watch all the stupid ass [ __ ] he wants
to watch spiderman five days in a row
over and over
right now we've been watching this uh
we go on youtube to watch old videos uh
movies and it's gently the master and
then you know like hong kong cinema like
they'll bring people that are wushu
champs right to do their movies but they
might not be from hong kong so when they
speak they're speaking mandarin and now
the rest of the cast is speaking
cantonese yeah so the whole movie in
titus is like is that chinese was that
chinese is that chinese i mean they're
all chinese there's so many chinese i'm
like i know it's i'm like it's because
jet li is a wushu champion for me i've
been explaining all this [ __ ] [ __ ] to
him he still doesn't get it like you
could just say that's mandarin and
that's cantonese
there's adults that wouldn't get that
yeah he's like two different chinese
well there's also adults who think that
japanese chinese filipino all that [ __ ]
is chinese so it doesn't [ __ ] matter
i agree i'm with them
squid game i don't watch that chinese
[ __ ]
you want me to read while i watch it's
crazy i don't i feel like when they lost
the office too it [ __ ] tomorrow ah
okay because like i literally have
peacock now just for the wow
okay that's a really good point like two
bucks a month or something no it's two
you still get ads do you get ads no no i
i once you like so yeah i don't know
maybe it's just like a more expensive
one but the one that we have yeah
there's no ads
because you can get free peacock but it
only gives you like up to season like
three or four on the office and then
when you pay you get all of them and
then you get the premium one with like
the extra stuff it's called super fan
episodes well they're like they're like
an extra 15 minutes long and there's all
these deleted scenes in it i can't even
tell the difference though
no i can on those sometimes when i wa
because i've seen i've watched the
office so much that i'm like
some some of them i don't like because
i'm like yeah isn't it i'm so used to
the original episode but
outtakes it's not it's it's like deleted
scenes so it's longer so it's a longer
episode i want to hear like bloopers and
stuff those are my favorite i watched
the bloopers on youtube but
i know yeah i feel i i feel like that
probably hit him the most because like
more competition too just definitely
more complicated did they say that
they're gonna do like a lower tier with
uh ads they're thinking of doing that
but their their main their main
objective is to figure out a way to get
people to not password share as much
or to give some kind of incentive for
people can't you just do the ip address
check thing or just limit you know they
don't want to if they were just to make
it illegal then no one would have
netflix like so it's like it's a thing
where they want to like give some kind
of incentive to the people not doing
that or to the person who originally
signed up like the first account maybe
gets something that the others the
shared ones don't because like espn you
can only you can only only like three
devices can watch on one account like a
ufc right yeah yeah that [ __ ] app is
useless though let me tell you i got
gripes with that [ __ ] hat
yeah right yeah it's the worst [ __ ]
app of all time yeah like i'll watch it
like if we're watching it in the like
the fights on the in the living room and
i have to go to the bathroom i'll bring
my ipad but then if like someone else
like because i have all these people in
my account if they're watching it that
won't work on my ipad then i have to
like sign out on my phone and text
someone to sign out on their tv so i can
just watch it on my ipad so you wanna
you wanna know one of the reasons i read
that i it was really [ __ ] interesting
uh there's some outlets that are saying
netflix is plunging because it got too
woke
really
i thought they weren't awoke enough like
they were letting dave chappelle's
special stay on that's dope i like like
i thought yeah you talking about the
content yeah content-wise yeah there's a
something like uh yeah they're saying
that like well i thought all of
hollywood is woke so it's like what do
you expect yeah you know do you want
more
alex jones [ __ ] or what like i don't get
like bro his show on netflix might kill
though you know it might dude it
probably would it would be hilarious
is it across the board though is it like
like the whole market every single
subscription app is taking the like 10
20 dick so if that's the case it could
be a swing back but if it's only netflix
and everyone else is crushing it i mean
peloton did pretty [ __ ] hard peloton
took a big ass
that makes the most sense it's like
people are just out again it's not like
how it was last year people were riding
bikes in the street except l.a feels it
still feels like it's a little bit weird
here like because people in la are weird
though yeah la is really [ __ ] weird
people yeah people some people in l.a
make it weird no they just recently said
no mask on planes is my [ __ ] still
wearing that [ __ ] yeah i'm like you
would like this yeah and they're mad
that you're not wearing bart made fun of
me the first day that the mask came off
i worked out with him and i came with my
mask he's like geo look alex wore his
mask in the gym yeah
loser
i was like damn my bad players
well cause remember when uh when they
said they lifted the mask band for the
planes
and then on the plane the announcer was
like guys we could take our mask off and
everyone was like cheering and then
after that video got around like people
who were against that were like how
could you cheer for the deaths of so
many people see look here's not what
they're cherry
look yeah it's not like yes we're
murderers
we want to kill everybody
i get it like yeah mass help whatever
but doesn't mean i want to still wear
them all the time you know what i mean
you could be on both sides of the team
but also you can wear it like no one's
stopping you yeah you wear a mask if you
want they're just the people that
actually believed all the fear-mongering
and propaganda and then they're just
still stuck on it and they don't they
don't they're in disbelief that it can
be lifted so easily and there's a lot of
people that really just can't go back on
how convicted they were about yeah what
was the truth to them exactly so now
they're just like no it's a way of life
well they're still covered out there we
have to still get it what are you guys
doing
definitely at a place where i'm like i
usually sound like that you know when
like they lifted it and like now there's
a new mask mandate like it went back and
forth i was like i don't know where
we're at right now so now whenever
there's like oh no mass man i'm like all
right that's the that's the rule right
now all right cool i can blame somebody
i'm like oh i don't know the government
like i don't know guys it's not me
that's my move that's my move like i
don't know where we're at there's too
many i gotta subscribe that's most
people i think most people don't want to
wear it but most people want to be law
abiding yeah so if the law flipped then
most people thank god i don't want to
wear you know that that's kind of how i
am it's like all right if it's required
or whatever yeah i'll wear it but yeah
if i don't have to wear it i'm not going
to wear it like i went to the post
office the other day and i walked in and
i saw these people with masks on and
then i saw the sign saying oh you need a
mask and i was like [ __ ] i don't have a
mask so i went to my living room yet
probably yeah i know then i was rifling
through my [ __ ] car to find a map oh
i found a mess perfect i walk in and
then i see five people with no mask on
and i'm like [ __ ] i'm just wasting time
so i might as well just stick to my
convictions yeah not where i'm at yeah
you know what i'm just i'm just
anti-mask now yeah i'm just anti-matter
like even when there are rules i'm like
[ __ ] it dude i cove is not even real i'm
just staying my ass at home how about
that
you're like you're not that different
man i'm retroactively anti-mask now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you